what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content that I'm
uploading on my channel and feel free to
subscribe and you can also offer
suggestions on topics and characters and
storylines and whatnot that we can have
discussions on later on in this channel
all right so considering our discussions
on external Manowar we pick up with the
introduction in Jack really in the extra
mana we're serious this looks really
cool because men Jack is kind of like
the other half like the opposite of EXO
Man O'War to a degree in the sense that
you know Erik of dacia boxy I really
want to pronounce it ah he of course has
the exosuit you know Shawn horror which
allows them to do some pretty insane
thing she's like Iron Man you know in
some ways but ninja acts just like a guy
with incredible ability so as you know
in terms of like his stealth guile so
and so what he doesn't have any like
superpowers to speak up and again you
know we talked about this in the last
video that's kind of valiant thing you
know it's like what we consider to be
something like superheroes existed in
the real world what would they look like
and this is really what you know what
dying gives us you know guys who were
basically spies you know international
minute mystery so on and so forth you
know heroes you soldiers of fortune that
kind of thing but we also get no alien
suits and so on and footwear that works
its way out in a way that actually
functions pretty damn well to be honest
we keep in mind you know Erik of dasya
is coming back to earth you know riding
here after having been away for sixteen
hundred years you know forced to serve
as a slave on an alien ship that was
really faster than the speed of light
when he gets back here everything he
knows and loves is gone the issue with
this is that between the time that he
first made his his escape and the time
that he arrived back on earth he didn't
really have time to like sit down and
soak in everything that was going on and
what he does is he basically arrives to
palencia the territory that was the
battle where the Visigoths fought
against the Romans and of course this is
sacred to him because this is one where
he was taken and two it was the field of
battle where he fought you know Romans
in a major campaign and so because of
this you know a young girl young a town
girl comes along basically says hey look
tell me what's going on here you know
what what year is it you know of course
she says was 2012 and so this is when he
begins to realize it is true that his
wife is dead the friends that he had are
gone you know age time just took them
away and that's time the issue is
there's no closure here you know his
wife was taken by the Romans but then
suddenly he was you know wish to board
an alien ship and taken away so he has
no idea what happened to her you know
where she brought in the Roman Society
found a man got married or what did she
spend the last days of her life and in
pain and agony he doesn't know any of
that stuff all he knows is that
everything that he's loved is basically
gone he's a man at a time and so because
of this you know he basically moves away
he you know ghost Peru he basically
travels the world and this offers him an
opportunity did he had ever really seen
before we just keep in mind you know in
the age when Erica Garcia had
but it was a time where you travel the
world I mean you kind of did to a degree
but only insofar that you are like a
nomadic tribe or you were a warring band
of people that just went from one
location to the next and that was really
it wasn't like you know an age of
exploration and because of that he's
seen parts of the world that he'd never
seen before but he's awful trying to
come to grips with his place in in
existence now the other half of this is
that he's currently being tracked down
by a handful of mercenaries that are
being led by a guy named Alexander
Dorian and the way do we know this is
happening is because there is something
that that's called gatherings and
gatherings are when the vine basically
communicate more or less telepathically
this kind of shared mind so to speak
with their plant limbs is to say
individuals who were left behind on
earth when they first appeared for the
purpose of just allowing the vine to
keep tabs on earth while they were out
in space doing whatever is they do you
know doing their hold the whole thing
whatever that thing happens to be and
the idea here is that Alexander Dorian
is one of the meaning he's one of sounds
and these plant wings that they bonded
left behind have infiltrated all facets
of world society not not American
society moral society governments
businesses you know average people
voting different things like that
they're all over the place and what
happened is that where the vine would
normally just leave things behind and
just kind of leave the plant wings here
the fact that Erica Darcy was able to
put on the Sean Haugh armor something's
considered to be sacred by the vine and
only the bravest vine warrior should be
allowed to try on they're basically
coming back to earth to get it and
what's being done here by zendaya is
basically sowing the seeds of what seems
to be an invasion in the sense of the
diviner saying look you know your task
alexander dorian and those you know who
around you is to seek out locate and
retrieve the armor do whatever you have
to do but get the armor back and bring
it to us if you're not able to do that
we're going to invade the earth and
we're going to take it back and so again
the reason why the vine are looking at
this is because of the idea that the
armor the exo-armor is wildly advanced
in comparison to any technology that
exists on earth by now and so if
humanity were to get a hold of you know
Erica Darcy if they were to I basically
you know capture him if they were to
take the armor from him and then
basically reverse engineer it they could
create a whole host of armors just like
that and then in turn you know
presumably challenge the Divine's
role in the universe you know possibly
even destroy them and so it's half
retrieving something to consider to be
sacred and half making sure that
humanity does
rise to challenge the vine in terms of
their abilities in their authority so
from here we pick up with these soldiers
of course tracking down Eric are
confronting him and he takes them out
quick fast and in a hurry I mean there's
no there's no real battle to be had here
it's more like they show up and then
they die and it's really cool because
then Diddy's like here's what the armors
table with us not only that Eric is oh
is a warrior I mean it's almost like
modern day you know soldier is going
against a Roman warrior or at least what
amounts to to somebody being equal to
Roman lawyers would they stand a chance
well the answer here is no because these
guys are skilled these guys are fighters
but they're not warriors you know
they're just guys who know how to kill
other people and so because of that the
attempt to take out Eric the attempt to
retrieve the armor the first effort
failed and so what they do and we show
it well is what happening here is you
know these guys basically call in this
specialist now Colin King is very much a
contract assassin to a Greek but there's
also a lot more to him than that in the
subsidy has no moral code it was all
moral compass but he basically does
whatever he's being paid to do so if
he's being paid in this instance to take
out Eric and to retrieve the armor then
that's exactly what he'll try to do and
he'll do it to the best of his abilities
in addition to this when he's actually
meeting with with his contact you know
he's shown pictures of Eric you said ëoh
told look the oh this guy Alexander
Dorian went in with this group that was
designed to take Eric out the issue is
that all of them died and the perception
is that Alexander Dorian died with all
of them and so it's almost like no one
knows that Alexander is wise and that's
important because that's going to become
a relatively significant aspect in terms
of how Alexander functions going forward
70 for a relatively short amount of time
now of course we know that Alexander
survives in terms of the fact that we
basically transition back to EXO and we
have EXO interrogating Alexander the
funny thing about this is that Cindy
does a really good job of focusing on
the concepts that Erik is a man out of
calm he's basically a god that doesn't
know what's going on here you know he's
basically primitive in terms of how he
lives in terms of how he used the world
deal in terms of how he functions he's a
very very primitive man and because of
this the ameen of those feed things add
some super advanced alien race from the
stars has come and taken me away and now
i'm back here on earth for him it's just
like those alien guys are bad and i
should take them out you know i should
take out anybody who is associated with
them and of course Alexander says look
you need my help you need me here yes
I'm
I'm one of them you know yes I speak in
their language but I'm not exactly
allied with them instead I'm somewhat of
a wild card in a sense that what they
want is the armored hand the armored /
or the earth is going to be invaded now
in the middle of this whole conversation
of course min Jack makes his presence
known and that's kind of the cool thing
here is it's like it's like a ninja
fighting a Roman warrior you know you
have this guy who's extremely good and
you know stealth guile so on and so
forth against a guy who's just really
good attacking a massive amount of
people and just chopping them all down
because of this min jack is easily able
to get the upper hand and basically take
out Erik you know a tranquilizer darts
with the intention of bringing him in a
problem arises however when Alexander
Dorian you know once they're aboard the
aircraft of min Jack the problem arises
when Alexander Dorian is rocked to one
of the gatherings and the vine
leadership basic recessed we're going to
invade the earth anyway you know yeah we
told you that we were only going to
invade if you were unsuccessful
achieving the armor we're going to go
ahead and invade anyway the reason why
is because you know we can't risk
humanity becoming aware of what's going
on with regards to our existence and so
on and so forth your existence there on
earth we're just going to invade we're
going to eliminate everyone and then
we're going to bring you guys back and
so because of this can Alexander
basically switches his allegiance
essentially what he's saying here but
and this is kind of a cool thing
Alexander will focus on this you know
here in a little while but what he does
is he basically freeze EXO you freeze
Eric and says we need you we need you to
fight on our behalf you know I need you
to help stave off the coming apocalypse
the coming invasion by the vine now
force min Jack shows up in the middle of
all this and it's exactly what we would
expect you is that what are you doing
you know and you just eventually goes on
the attack against against EXO but it's
almost like he's this guy that always
prepares for every instance for every
situation
he's always got contingencies and play
and because of the fact that you know
they're in a confined space because of
the fact that it works against to me
basically bailed out now again this is
not cowardice this is a classic example
of like Sun Tzu's the art of war that's
exactly what it is if you're fighting an
enemy and you're in a terrain that
doesn't benefit you leave and move to a
terrain that does benefit you if it
means that your enemy just doesn't come
and attack you well then you're safer
for the day you're better off for it if
it means they do attack you then they're
fighting on your terrain always engage
in a conflict where you can almost
guarantee that you have the upper hand
or you'll have a strong advantage in
some form or fashion it may mean the
upper hand maybe you guys fight to a
stalemate but eventually means that
you're not caught unawares you're not
fighting on quicksand and so because of
that at
Xander says look we have to get out of
here they crash land in IANA I think
it's how you pronounce it but again it's
really just kind of interrogation that's
going on now the cool thing about this
in terms of men jag is again this is a
man of almost limitless resources and
these these resources come to bear what
he basically sends out a zillion probes
into the sky and says find XO Man O'War
find Alexander Dorian lock onto their
heat signatures when you locate them
give me audio and so he's basically
listening to their entire conversation
and this is when men Jack begins to
learn what's going on behind the scenes
because remember Alexander and XO don't
know they're being watched so it's not
like they're putting on a show in order
to trick them Jack he's seeing them for
the truth of what they are and
Alexander's basically saying look the
vine are coming you know sure you might
want to attack me you know that's fun if
you want to kill me we can do that at a
later date but it's beef that you have
needs to be put on hold we need to worry
about the vine we have to worry about
them coming here you know retrieving the
armor and annihilating humanity in
addition to that min Jack is extremely
skilled in terms of his abilities what
do you like him or not he's extremely
skilled in terms of capability you guys
need to work together in order to stave
off this threat that's will be kind of
that we're ninja he makes his way to
Alexander and XO you know to basically
kind of confront them about what it is
he's hearing Alexander gives us the
whole spiel about himself and what he
says is these plantings you know what he
is they've been here for for thousands
of years you have over a thousand years
but Alexander himself has basically come
to better understand humanity and he's
come to identify with humanity yes he's
a member of the vine race but he's a
human first he believes in humanity and
the reason why is not because of the
fact that Hannity has order structure
it's nothing bad craft it is the idea
that humanity knows what it means to
feel humanity knows what it means to
love humanity knows buting they know
pain they know struggle you know even if
the experiences that people have put
each other through have been of the
utmost extreme when it's you know world
war ii world war one different things
like that humanity's ability to feel is
what helps us differentiate between
what's right and what's wrong it's what
gives us rule of law it's what creates a
social contract and an ordered social
structure what I understand is the vine
don't have that the vine don't feel they
don't have emotions they're basically
just beings that exist and what he says
is you know there's nothing worse than
seeing an individual in organisms that
just exist but never really lives
they're just there there's nothing worse
than seeing that and so he's like you
know look this is why I don't identify
with the vine because we're going to
wipe out
beauty that is humanity we can't allow
that to happen
humanity is capable of incredible and
beautiful things and we have to allow
that to thrive we have to allow it to
grow and that is intrinsically the
danger of what the line do because what
what Alexander says is divine don't
really go in and conquer they don't
plant plant means on a planet for the
purpose of feeding rebellion and then
conquering that time that's not what
they do they just leave them behind for
the purpose is just monitoring a world
basically putting a flag in a planet and
saying the vine have been here that's
more or less what it amounts to but the
danger of this is that those individuals
who are left behind some of them will
basically defect they'll work against
the vine because the day's come to
identify with the race that they've been
designed to mimic and so because of this
you know during this conversation what's
NIM Jack arrived it's a little bit of a
confrontation a little bit of a
misunderstanding and the things that min
Jack's like look I'm not here to fight
you because I'm here to ask you about
what's going on I'm here to ask you
about what's happening because ninja
doesn't want to be eradicated anything
you know any more than anybody else and
so right now it's just one of these
situations where the enemy of my enemy
is my friend
you know and so we're you says look if
the vines are coming here to conquer the
earth basically wipe out humanity then
I'll fight on your behalf it doesn't
mean we're friends not by any stretch of
the imagination it means that we're
temporary allies now the other half of
this is that min Jack wants proof
because it's one thing for him to say
look I'll fight on your behalf
it's another for him to say I need to
know that you're telling the truth and
so what happens is Alexander says look
the people who do your contract with you
right now they're the exact same thing I
am they're members of the vine they're
manipulating me and when in Jack's has
proved it Alexander appears before a
gathering of the vine and various of the
members and says look you know I'm being
held captive in this territory that he's
not actually being held captive and he's
being held captive in a but he says he's
being held captive and beat and he says
you have to send in Jack to rescue me
well one of these contacts responds and
Sims that message to ninja saying they
ask that is over in this location you
have to go and find him and so he says
look you know that's the case you're
being manipulated you're being burnt
you're being being controlled to
engineer this destruction of humanity
and this is really the only proof that
NIM Jack needs I mean this is basically
him saying okay I'm basically being
tricked here and so in response to that
he along side I launched my experimental
war and Alexander could basically take
off to London now the way they do this
it's actually really really cool it's
actually really interesting Alexander
goes to one of his fellow plantings or
so to watch there
spy among the ranks of our group here on
earth we don't know who the Spy is but I
need to get to London so that we can
route this file out with the partners
once they get onboard the vessel sadik's
basically killed you know there's plenty
that that our dinner was meeting with
sadik's executed by ninja you know they
basically fly off to London for the
purposes of basically eliminating
Patrick you know one of these plant are
planting Tuesday for the purpose of
ensuring the divine are able to arrive
on earth and conquer it effectively so
if once they get to the headquarters of
mi6 again where Patrick is operating out
of another instance where they've
infiltrated all these different
organizations around the world
Patrick understands what's happening any
basically says or he engineers this
failsafe which is basically the other
plantings that are there killing all the
normal humans in mi6 and preparing to
attack the exosuit and take it away from
Eric now force ditch fails in
spectacular fashion and as soon as they
land a hit but it doesn't work in their
favor and the reason why is because in
the middle of their desire to go
retrieve it min Jack shows up and then
Jack starts taking out each and every
one of these guys so it's kind of cool
seeing Eric and min Jack working
together because it's like the oil and
vinegar sort of situation and the two of
them bounce talk to each other you have
this the suit that has incredible
abilities but then you also have NIM
Jack who's just a regular guy fighting
off this fight ultimately saving the day
and so because of this we're kind of
left me with things being a little bit
ambiguous in the sense that this vine
invasion will be coming at some point
along the line or at least it seems like
it'll be coming some point along the
line but we also have the vines
meeting with Alexander during one of
these gatherings and saying we know that
you're you're sly we know that you
you've turned traitor we know that you
work against us and what will happen is
we will continue with this invasion and
when we do we will execute you along
with everybody else and so what the
story does is it ends on the auspices of
what's going to happen what's going to
happen when the binds show up on earth
with the intention of annihilating the
whole of humanity and basically killing
everyone who is there wiping out all
facets of humanity as it exists but if
you guys are new here to come in to
explain make sure you guys with a sub
button to become part of the rod force
you guys enjoyed this video make sure
you drop a like and yeah I will catch
you all in please
you